hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet this is a clip from my
interview with serial entrepreneur noah
kagan and we're talking about advice
that every student needs to hear while
they are a student so i hope you enjoy i
think
in in in school in college and
university you've just got so much spare
time on your hands and i don't think we
really appreciate this when we're going
through it but when you start working
especially if you're working like a
normal kind of a normal job like nine to
five it ends up never being nine to five
you end up at work until seven if not
later every day you end up having so
much less time on your hands and so when
you're at school i think really take
advantage of all of that just ridiculous
amount of free time you have and
occasionally i i get messages from
people being like hey when i get home i
do my homework and then it's time for
bed and that's just unfathomable because
if you get home from school like say
five you do your homework for let's say
two hours you still got between seven
and eleven to just do whatever you want
and high school is the time where for
example i i learned to code i taught
myself design i took on lots of these
different hobbies that now looking back
i'm so glad i went down these rabbit
holes because at the time it didn't seem
like it would be particularly helpful or
just like oh this is cool i'm making
like ten dollars here and there making a
website but now like those skills
compound on themselves so much over time
and you feel really glad that you spent
that time in high school having said
that i just i did spend about four hours
a day playing world of warcraft for
three years happiest time of my life but
now you can make a living doing that
though which is wild yeah that's true
that's true but one thing i want to
highlight though i thought about this
with twitch because my friends work at
league of legends and so forth and
we see people that are twitch people
that make a million dollars that's only
the top ten
and so i think the thing that's
interesting there is that you can find
follow your passions so i think people
are asking how do i find my passion try
a lot of things out and find out the
stuff that you're like excited to keep
doing
and so with the twitch stuff if you're
not able to make it in the top 10
there's still a lot of opportunity to
start businesses or get jobs in gaming
right like you can start a marketplace
for gamers or you can sell books for
teaching people how to game or you can
do gaming parties there's a lot of
opportunities if you're not in that
thing for me i think where i've done
success in my career by my own self i
think success is a horrible word by the
way yeah i think it's a dirty word
because success is what we tell everyone
else yeah oh ali is successful
this person is successful and i think we
have to decide our own metric
of success uh in this life i think
that's almost one of the most important
things and so for me it's like
when i've chased money
and opportunity
i've been less fulfilled i've sustained
it and i've made less money when i just
said hey i really love doing these
things
i don't really care how much money it
ends up making
i've made the most money
yeah that's my theory for it as well
it's like
the first question is this thing fun and
if it's fun then i'll probably do it if
it's not fun but makes money then i
probably won't i think early on i was
more open to doing things that weren't
fun but that made money but now i
realize actually
especially once you've got some level of
success it just makes so much more sense
to do the stuff that that fills you with
joy as corny and hippie as that sounds
i think that's exactly it man
learn a new hobby learn a new skill
level up what you're doing like the
existing stuff that you're doing because
that is the stuff that will synergize
firstly with your studies it'll make it
more interesting like for me so many
more doors have opened in medicine
because of the fact that i can make a
pretty looking website than because of
the fact that i'm i scored one percent
higher than someone else in an anatomy
exam i've been invited onto the
committee of this like super big plastic
surgery charity just because i could
make their website look cool and i was
like hey you guys need a cool looking
website here are some examples i'll do
it for free you know and they were like
sure come on board that's awesome and i
got access to this whole network of like
amazing consultant plastic surgeons and
doing cool stuff and then off the back
of that that led to me helping develop
an app for like remote augmented reality
remote assistance for surgery in
low resource areas and
all of this stuff came about because of
my interest in web design not because
i spent my summer holidays get trying to
get a head start on learning anatomy and
so that would be one thing that i would
strongly advise anyone who's a student
at the moment
use your free time to
learn the other stuff don't worry about
using your free time to learn the
student stuff because that happens by
default in your day job
you know i double majored in business
and economics and i literally don't
think i've learned used one thing from
that after i graduated
all of my learning is experience and so
i think what you're saying is a great
point is like just start exploring
different things start helping different
people start either physically being
around other people or online like part
of your community be a part of ali's
community there's a bunch of people here
that want to be more productive that are
thinking about exploring life and you'll
be able to get ahead now get ahead but i
think you'll be able to find your
answers faster
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day